[Music]
Building agents with Amazon Nova ACT and
MCP.
I'm excited today because we're going to
build intelligent autonomous AI systems
that can help you build,
scale, and improve your applications and
business. My name is Dewan Lightoot and
I'm joined by
swap. Swap. Yeah,
there we go. There you go. My name is
Dwan Lifford and I'm joined by Hey, I'm
Banjo Bami. I'm a solic architect here
at AWS.
Now, this is the AI engineer worldfare
and I've been in tech over 15 years and
right now is the most exciting time for
me in my entire career. And one of the
reasons for this excitement is agents.
How many of you right now are been
building agentic systems?
I love it. So when we talk about agentic
AI, I think it's important that we level
set from an AWS perspective.
There are three key terms we need to
think about. First, the ability to plan.
A agent gets a prompt. It gets an
objective and it determines the actions
that need to be taken. So it creates the
plan and then it takes actions on those
actions by using things like tools. Now
the last piece, the third piece and
probably the most interesting is the
reasoning where the agent is able to
evaluate the results and determine if it
needs to update the plan and take
additional actions until the objective
is complete.
This is an agent.
Now when we actually break down the
architecture,
I think it's important to take a look at
this because we have the user input, we
have the agentic system, we have the
possibility of some type of human in the
loop and then we have the generator
response. Now when we dive a little
deeper, there's some components of this
agentic system. We have the LLM.
We have a knowledge base with external
information that we want may want to
provide. We have guardrails to say to
the model don't do this or to ground the
model with the truth from our knowledge
base to say okay is this actual relevant
information. Is this accurate to the
information we're receiving from the
knowledge base? And then we have access
to additional tools, memory, or we may
need to talk to additional agents or
LLMs like Amazon Nova ACT through
something like MCP.
And we have the ability to design our
own flows for these systems.
Now, the most interesting piece that I
think a lot of us are probably focused
on when we're building these systems is
around the continuous evaluation
framework. Like how do we know if we're
using the right LLM? How do we know if
our prompt is consistent, accurate, or
even optimized for the performance we're
expecting? And then how do we even judge
our system? How do we rate that and
determine that that it's actually
solving the problems that we need or
intend?
Now, once we have this, we need to log
this information and then have some type
of subject matter expert and determine
how can we improve this system. And this
is the iterative approach. So we're
always trying to improve and optimize
our agentic system.
Now continuing on this continuing on
with this story. Now there are some use
cases that we should be building these
systems for. Like if it's complex task
and we don't know which tools should be
used, how many tools should be used and
we want the model to leverage his reason
and capabilities. Well, this is a great
use case for a gentic system. But if
it's something that is just one step,
our traditional if this then that
approach is probably the best solution,
right? We don't always need to provide
some type of agentic system for
something that can be done with a
traditional solution.
Now when we talk about agents on AWS,
there are three approaches and
perspectives we should think about.
First is going to be to specialize using
something like Amazon Q. How many of you
are have used Amazon Q?
The there's Amazon Q in the console to
help solve your problems on AWS. In the
console, there's Amazon Q developer
inside of your IDE. And right now, one
that I'm I think most excited about is
Amazon QLI agent. How many of you have
used that?
For me, if you if you are into
increasing your productivity, using a CI
a CLI agent has helped me tremendously.
You from editing a video, it can do
that. Summarizing a document, reading my
entire codebase. Like today for one of
my demos, I had some code and I was
trying to figure out why wasn't it
working. I said, "Analyze this code and
tell me what you see. Let me know the
APIs that it's calling." Well, I looked
up the APIs. Well, it didn't match my
APIs in the API gateway. So, when the
code was deployed, it wasn't deployed
with the right APIs. So, the agent was
able to help me save a ton of time by
just analyzing the code and tell me what
it saw because I never seen the code
before, right? So, that's what these
tools are able to um to help us do. The
next is fully managed. If you're using
Amazon Bedrock, you're able to leverage
Amazon Bedrock agents to build and
manage agents inside of AWS. And today
what we're going to be focusing on is
the DIY the do-it-yourself approach by
using strands agents. This is allows you
to not just leverage Amazon bedrock but
also leverage models through other
providers using light lm.
Now when we talk about strands agents
strands agent was announced about a
month ago. I want to say something about
a month ago. This is open source
extremely lightweight. So if you use
other agent FL frameworks, it's like
that. But the implementation is you'll
see in the code how easy it is to build
a aentic system or a agent itself in a
few lines of code and already get
started. I built a multi- aent solution
in about under 50 lines of code.
And so when we break down strands
agents, there are three components. We
have a prompt, we have a LLM, and we
have tools. So you create a function
called let's say a get weather tool
right you define your agent you give it
a prompt and it's already implemented
and you'll see in the code as Banjo goes
through it here in a moment
now taking it a step further as Danielle
presented today on Amazon Nova Act these
models are able to do some really cool
things and this is another thing that
I'm excited about Amazon Nova Act is a
research preview model. And
the capabilities of this allows you to
use a prompt or give instructions and
take complex tasks and do things like
browse the internet to find research or
to research or to search on Amazon.com
to find the top list of widgets, right?
And then return them and then add them
to your cart. So you'll see how we can
leverage this not just using the SDK for
Amazon Nova ACT but also by leveraging
MCP which leads us into the last piece
which I think when we talking about
agents I don't think we would be here
today as fast as we have moved if it
wasn't for MCP. How many of you are
leveraging MCP today? Modern contest
protocol. How many of you have built
your own MCP servers?
I built several um I got two that I use
all the time. One, how many of you use
Obsidian?
Okay, so for my documentation, I built
the Obsidian MCP server. This allows me
to save all my documents, reference all
my documents, and just my entire
workflow is streamlined because of this
MCP server I use right there. But I also
use one for my bookmarks. I built the
bookmark manager because every Friday
I'm restarting my computer and I lose my
bookmarks. I save them and I forget
about them. But now I can just say save
this bookmark. It gives it a
description, gives it a title, give it a
date and I can even add notes so I can
remember where this bookmark. So now
when I open up QCLI, I can say hey I'm
looking on the top. I'm looking for um
some information on MCP. Can you tell me
all the bookmarks that I have? Then
it'll find it. Can you tell me the ones
I saved last week? And so these this is
the power that we have today. But with
that being said, I think it's time that
we all start building. Banjo's going to
take over. But if you you open your
laptops and log on to this link, this is
going to take you to a workshop
environment where you have access to an
Amazon account where Banjo is going to
walk you through building out today's
workshop. I thank you for your time.
Cool. All right. So, uh, this is going
to be a hands-on workshop. So, we've
provisioned an AWS account for everybody
here. So you don't have to install
anything on your computer. Everything is
going to be done through the browser.
And I always say the hardest part of the
workshop is just getting started. So
some of my colleagues are also here. So
raise your hand AWS folks that are here
to support. Uh so we're going to take
some time to just get logged into an
environment. We're going to set up a VS
Code server, enable models, uh get the
Nova Act API key. So again, this is the
hardest part of the workshop, just
getting started. Uh so let's take some
time to just get into the environment
and I'll follow along as well.
So, and this is uh again everything is
you don't have to install anything on
your computer. You don't have to use
your own AWS account. Everything is
provisioned for you. So, but while
that's loading, let me briefly walk
through the three modules of the
workshop. Uh so, the workshop is really
about how you can use Nova Act. So, the
first module is just getting started
with Nova Act. We're going to make an
API call that the second part of the
module is going to make an MCP server
that can leverage a Nova Act. And then
finally, we're going to use the strands
agent to hook everything together. So
that's kind of the the three steps
you'll go through at this workshop and
all the code is available via the link
on GitHub so you can try it out on your
own as well. Uh but yeah trying to get
started here if you can't follow along
I'm going to be doing up here so don't
worry too much and again all the code is
available so you can try it outline uh
offline.
Okay, so the first things first, uh, if
you're following along, make sure to
click this open AWS console button.
Again, we provision the AWS account. You
know, don't log into your own AWS
account. Don't try to create a new one.
Everything is uh previsioned here
already. So, going to click clicking
that button to open up your AWS account.
So, logged into my AWS account.
So the first thing we do in an AWS
account, we're going to enable uh Amazon
Bedrock models. So Amazon Bedrock think
of as a serverless API to access
different foundation models and you can
build lots of gen applications in it. So
it has capabilities like knowledge
bases, guard rails, you can build agents
on top of it for anything you need to
build uh AI agents or geniary
applications. Amazon Bedrock has
capabilities for that. But for this
workshop, we're just going to enable
specific models. So going to enable
specific models. You can click the
Amazon models and we used the Claude 37,
3.5 IQ, and 3.5 sonnet. So those are the
ones we're going to use for this
workshop.
And
that's going to request access there.
And again, all the instructions are also
in this workshop as well. Uh, so we
could follow along, but I'm just going
to go through it just for sake of time.
And then the next part once we get the
model access, there's a VS Code server
that has everything set up already. So
I'm just going to go in there
and if the URL and password is there,
you can log in to your VS Code server
with everything installed.
and I'm also going to log into Amazon Q.
So, Amazon Q is our U ID extends in to
help you write code.
U we have time you can sign up through a
builder ID completely free. You don't
need uh AWS account. You don't need to
put in your credit card. You can just uh
log in through there. I already have an
account so just feed it up but it puts
uh nice little AI agent there. I can ask
questions, update code, etc. So it's uh
I'll show you some examples of go
through some of the code. So
So who's gotten to this point setting up
all the models workshops because this is
once you get all this done then that's
when the real fun begins. So does
getting a pulse if I need to slow down
or
slow down a bit. Okay, I'll wait a bit
again. raise your hand if you're stuck
anywhere. Questions, we have uh agents
that can come around and support you.
So, I'm going to pause for a little bit.
Any general questions while we're
waiting?
Oh, yeah. So, this workshop uh again all
the code is available online. Uh this
workshop available as well. So, you can
also look through that. There's a
website called workshops.awws. AWS
and when you go there you can do
something like uh Nova act and then it's
the only worktop that shows up. So you
can always go to workshops.Waww
search nova act and this workshop will
show up so you can see all the
instructions all the code and run this
uh on your own.
Okay. And then the last thing, uh,
because we're going to use Nova Act, we
actually need to get a Novaact API key.
So, if you go to Nova, Amazon.com,
it this is a website that you can use
the Amazon Nova model. So, you can do
like chatting, generating images, uh,
speaking with Nova, uh, generate videos,
but then also this is where the the ACT
API key is generated. So, if you're
following along and you want to generate
your key, again, it's free to log in.
You can use your Amazon.com uh like when
you order something on Amazon.com
account to log into this and then you
can just generate a key here and it'll
be able to access that
Oops. Okay. So, I'm going to walk
through what module one is. Uh before I
get has anybody got in here? Just quick
pulse check. If not, you know, I'll
continue. I know the Wi-Fi is slow, so
it might be hard. So, I'll just continue
on. Uh but yeah, the first one we got to
see how Nova Act works. Uh how how the
actual code looks like. Uh generated the
key. uh need to export the key and then
kind of running the first script which
is actually going to open amazon.com uh
and we're actually going to look for the
first coffee maker. So let me see how
that uh code looks like. Let's go here.
Make this bigger.
Oops.
So very simple code uh with Nova Act
it's again it's all on Python SDK I so I
decide what a page to go to. So go to
amazon.com I say I want you to search
for a coffee maker. I say select the
first result and I say get the title of
that product page. So uh very simple if
you ever done kind of web automation
before of something like uh Selenium or
Playright you probably have to like look
for this diff tag you know look at this
H1 tag grab this information. a lot of
manual processes of actually inspecting
the actual website. Here I'm just saying
click the search bar, find something
like I don't have to specify click this
tag, do that. So it makes it much more
easier to engage with the website as a
natural human would instead of like
looking through divs and trying to find
this P tag specifically. So uh this is a
great way to just uh you know use Nova
Act right out of the box. So I'm going
to uh run this
so we can see
examples.
All right. All right. So, added my key.
Going to what happens when I run this
file.
Give it a second.
Oops, we failed. All right, let's start
over.
One.
Ah, okay. I know.
Got to run out of this. Let's start that
over.
Yeah, question.
So just to explain why is Banjo running
that command? It's running F XVFB. It's
a frame buffer where it runs your X11
system. What happens there? Nova act
actually goes and clicks a mouse on a
browser. That's why it needs to be run
like that. Otherwise, it has no guey. So
this is just kind of a way to emulate um
a graphical user interface on this Linux
box. Thank you, Darko. Yeah, since we're
running everything in the the cloud on a
browser, I'm saying, you know, open a
browser again, but it's already in a
browser. So that's why it crashed. So I
had to put that frame buffer command. Uh
and yeah, the workshop kind of walks
through why we did that. But you can see
uh what is going on when Nova act says,
I'm going to search for a coffee maker.
I'm at the Amazon homepage. My task is
to search for this. So it's
understanding what it's doing. I see the
search spark has copy maker. I'm at the
search spark here and now it actually
puts the actual log of the actual HTML
file. So it's taking screenshots. You
can see what it looks like. It got the
first results. I'm on the copy maker
page. It selected it. And now I got the
title of the now it says, you know,
what's the title of this product page?
All right. Got this Black Decker 12 copy
maker. my task to return the title of
the product page product title. It got
that and it ended the session and then
it also creates a a video log that I can
actually look at to see what it did for
each for everything it did in this webm
file.
Yeah. Question.
Yeah.
So the question was does it reason about
the page in terms of pixels or in terms
of text? Yeah. So it's actually looking
through the actual uh the page itself.
So you see in this video it sees it
looks at the page. I can see what's in
the page. So it's it's a large language
model train. So it can actually see the
actual the page is doing. So it's not
looking at like like the H1 tag or
whatnot. It understands the context of
that particular page. It can see that's
a search box. Okay, I'm going to go
click through that search box. So yes,
it understands the pixel level of what's
on that actual page.
So this is kind of the video. It's hard
to see. Make it bigger.
Sped up.
So, it opens the page. It goes to the is
able to type in coffee maker there. Um,
it gets that information, clicks the
button. So, even with all the ads and
everything, the video can understand the
task, clicks that, and it gets the
information back. So, that's and that
was a couple lines of code. So, you can
extrapolate to other type of workflows
you can do for searching through things.
Sorry, I have a and I have a question.
Yeah. So when you what I have
experienced with these kind of
frameworks is that when you run this on
a server environment um services like
Cloudflare will block the access and
maybe do a capture challenge. How do we
solve that using Q? Yeah. So with uh so
using Amazon Nova so it doesn't do
captures. It doesn't do things of that
nature. So it's it's meant for like
workflows you understand but yes it's
not going to bypass captures and other
things of that nature as well. So it's
made for like going to amazon.com or
look through a booking site. But if
something that's like requires like a
human or it wants to you can't bypass
that
you you wouldn't use Nova Act for that
use case. If you need to pass a capture
of something else that use another
technology this is not meant to like
overtake humans, you know, it's more
like I'm helping them augment things but
not if there's a capture involved then
you have to use a different technology
for that. It's also a preview. It's also
a preview. Yes. So this is a research
preview as well. So if that's a very
good use case, you know, leave feedback
on the Nova the website. So is is human
and loop possible at all with it yet?
Well, with this this one, it's no
because I'm writing all the code here.
So but again, this is Python code. So I
could probably put in something here
like, you know, ask something, make an
API call here. So this is, you know,
it's a Python code. you might be able to
create some type of uh workflow that
might augment like wait for a human
response or whatnot because the browser
is happening in like headless mode but
could you make it work with a browser to
human is also seeing at the same time?
Yes. So it can pause and wait for
somebody put in like a password or
credentials or do a capture and then
once it receives that works continue on
the workflow. You could do yeah because
right now I I ran it in headless mode
but yes it can also run uh you know it
would open up the browser. If I ran this
on my MacBook, I would open up a Chrome
browser and go through that session.
Also, if you're running it and you
wanted to bypass something that has two
factor, if you're already logged into
say Amazon.com and then you run a code,
it's going to use your credentials in
that browser session to continue on to
perform that task. So, that's something
that you can do as well.
Cool.
So, let me Oops.
And then one other thing you can also do
multi- uh you know parallel execution.
So my last my next example is actually
I'm trying to find multiple monitors and
I wanted to compare them all at once. So
I'll show you how that code looks like
so I can check for the monitor extract
information. I'm setting you know I want
I'm defining what I want. So again, I'm,
you know, saying I want to find the
price, the rating, the size. Uh, go to
amazon.com.
Uh, I set it headless mode this time. So
I don't need to do the frame buffer. I
start multiple threads. It looks for
each monitor simultaneously because each
of these are individual tasks. So I can
paralyze them instead of waiting it to
to go through. I I define the list of
monitors I want to go through, start the
thread, and then it starts executing and
finds the the results of the monitors.
So I can run that in the background.
So starting the three parallel threads
and it's so again it's running in
headless mode so it's going to be able
to do this in the background where we
can see kind of what the model is
thinking how it navigates through the
web page.
Yep.
I I have tried to use Nova uh in the
past April and uh it worked for the
first time but once I did it again it
triggered the capture. Is this something
that has been already resolved or is
this happening because I think the
website and it was Amazon in this case
it was detecting it was a bot and uh is
there like an LLM.txt
or robots.txt txt that can declare it.
So Nova actor is a GitHub repo. So you
could go there and just grab that. But
it's it's working now. Like I'm running
it, you know, I just I this is just live
code I'm doing right now. Like uh I just
exported my API key, started running it.
So uh you can try it in the workshop.
Yeah, I mean it's it's ready to go.
We're building right now.
And you can kind of see that it's going
on in the background what it's doing. Uh
I've looked at this monitor, the Dell
monitor. I'm at the Amazon homepage.
It's like it's going through looking
through the search results. It's saving
things. So, you can see it's running in
parallel. It got the information for the
one of the first ones. So, it's going as
I just set that up and it can execute
that. So, if you have some type of uh I
don't know like daily news thing. You
need to go to the website and get news
or something and like have a report Nova
and there's no API for that. This is one
way you can encodify how to do that kind
of search and get the information.
Have a question. Yeah. I'm wondering so
how successful is this in terms of like
more ambiguous test because I I ran the
Amazon demo and that worked but I'm
wondering could I just add Google there
and and how like how vague and sort of
how much does it know when it's
navigating through like I was thinking
like if I wanted to return a pair of
sunglasses that broke would I would I be
able to just say like start in Google
and then find this company's website
find a way to you know engage support
open a ticket like how much sort of like
how vague can you be and how smart is it
currently would that would that yeah I
mean the more instruction you give
obviously the better but it's able to
understand how to navigate a website
that's what the model's trained on so if
you say you know go to this sunglasses
website it doesn't it probably wasn't
trained on a specific sunglass website
but it can understand that button
support you know this but click a ticket
so understand kind of the the general
knowledge of how to navigate the website
but if there's something very intricate
about that website you're going to have
to encode it in the text like make sure
you click button an experts or whatever.
So, it understands how to navigate
websites. Got it. And does it understand
when it's failed? Yeah, sometime
sometimes I've seen it sometimes get
stuck in a loop and like, oh no, I keep
scrolling. I keep scrolling. I keep
scrolling. It doesn't know when to stop.
So, it again, this is in research
preview, so things are getting better.
The model's getting updated behind the
scenes, but it's not like it's not AGI.
So, that's got it. And one last
question. Um, h how is it in terms of
navigating like distrustful parts of the
internet? I mean there's a lot on the
internet that we see and we know is not
to be trusted or it's something not to
be followed. H how have you sort of
worked around that problem? Yeah because
again it is a model in the background so
it's going to understand like if you're
doing something it's not going to want
to click that or might be there
safeguards in place. So that's built
into the model but again uh it is in
research preview. You still have to
explicitly say what buttons to press for
certain actions but again the model it
isn't LLM trained. is going to be able
to understand the nuances and say if it
can't take this action or can't do that
that that could happen. But I haven't
seen that use case. But if you keep
pushing it, maybe you'll find those
those things. Well, the thing I had in
my mind is like if you go to a site
where you have to download a link,
sometimes there's an ad that says
download a link and you know that that's
just an ad trying to get your attention
would the model know or is that some is
that like for example like in the the
Amazon.com it shows an ad for something
but it said find the first thing. I was
able to scroll past that ad and click
something. So the model understands the
task you give it. So yes, it can
understand that. Thank you.
All right. So this this just finished.
Yeah, that's really quick. It showed it
was able to find all the models, give me
the size, the rating, the price for each
of the monitors. So again, it it
executed that on parallel. It got me the
nice information. And that that's kind
of the idea of like it can do parallel
execution in the background. So you
don't have to wait for it and don't see
it actually clicking through the the
task and you get your information.
All right, one more question then we'll
move on to the MCP part. So Nova is
specifically meant to be used with a
browser. Correct. Uh so Nova act. So
Amazon Nova is a family of models on
Amazon. So if you go to this website
Nova Amazon.com
uh you see there are different
foundation models like Nova Pro,
Premiere, Light Micro. These are like
the text understanding models. So like
your typical LLM calls. There's also an
image model called Nova Canvas can
generate images. There's a video real
called Nova Real where can generate uh
videos uh and then it's also a speech
model text speech to speech called Nova
Sonic. So Nova is a foundation of found
uh foundation models by Amazon to do all
these type of tasks and acts as just
another one for browser automation. Are
there plans to expand this like beyond
the browser so that we can someday take
actions in Slack or IDE or anything
outside of the browser? Maybe some of
the team is here so maybe talk with them
later.
Right. Thank you.
All right. So I'm going to move on to
the MCP part. Banjo. Yep. Nova Act is
only available in US.
Yes. Right now, Nova Act is only
available in the US. It's in preview, so
it's just getting started. So, if you
log in from like a different uh account
like address like UK or something, it
might not it won't work. So, it only
works in the US at the moment. Yes.
Right. One more question over there and
then I'm going to move on.
Samsung
might be Oh.
[Laughter]
Your Amazon.com is different. I don't
know. Yeah, because it is opening up a
different browser. So, it could have
clicked something differently. Yeah. So,
yeah, that's right. Look at the video
preview video playback to see what your
results were. Right. Yeah.
Oh, one more. Okay. One more quick quick
one. Are there plans to support
persisting browsing data such as cookies
in the cloud browser? So right now it's
opening up its own uh browser, but you
can also set like your own like Chromium
profile and open up that browser. So
everything you have saved there like if
you want to log into your stuff, you can
set your own custom browser, but by
default it opens up a new like
completely new browser without anything
saved.
All right. So I want to show uh I
actually made an MCP server for Nova
ACT. So a module tool is going through
uh MCP and I can kind of show you what I
did for the MCP server. Uh in fact we
can use Amazon Q here. So I'm going to
ask it uh
can you tell me about the Nova
ACT MCP server?
Tell me what it does
and oops.
So tell me about the Nova act MCP
server.
So you can see it's going through um
integrates Nova act browser and MCP. It
has the browse session tool, browser
action, execute parallel task, take
screenshots, close browser, list
results. So I created these different
aspects of the MTCP server. So I can use
something like claw desktop or cursor or
Amazon QCLI to say you know open
Amazon.com and find information for me.
So it's it's portable. It understands uh
so I don't have to actually write code.
I can say so go to amazon.com and find
me the co the first coffee maker. It
will actually write all that code I did
in the initial one to do that or the
multimonitor. So I wrote wrote a bunch
of code to do this. If I just said you
know get me these three monitors to get
the price. it would actually write all
the Nova act code it needs to do that
using the MCP server. So that's kind of
the power of MCP that I just describe a
task and then I can it will encode the
actual browse action things it needs to.
So and I also made an MCP client that
can actually interpret that. So oops
uh it connects to the MCP server it runs
the code and it's able to use query
bedrock. uh I am using a model so I'm
using cloud 3.5 sonnet here because I'm
is an MCP client and needs to have an LM
behind that and then it's able to you
know understand which tools to use uh
run the code and open up the browser and
whatnot. So let me just run the example
here.
So module two.
So
we are open the file. Just did that.
We ask Amazon Q to explain the file to
us. And now we're actually going to run
it. So Python 3. And then I can open
this up.
Okay. So, let's be adventurous. So,
somebody give me a query to try since
anyone has an idea. Yeah, I'm going to
just ask it and do something. So,
someone give me an idea of what to run
another act. Fix Wi-Fi.
Uh, how would you fix the Can you find a
website to find fix website? can find
let's see website to fix Wi-Fi use
headless mode
I spelled it wrong but let's see
all right goes to google.com how to fix
Wi-Fi problems troubleshooting guide in
the box and press enter return a list of
the websites title descriptions
All right,
it's going through that. So, it open
google.com. Uh, how to fix Wi-Fi
problems. I see an empty search bar
where I can type queries for search
information. I should type how to fix
Wi-Fi problem. So, you can see it's
understanding what to do. It oh, it hit
a recapture page. So, okay, the search
results are not viewable. Blah blah. So,
so see it looks like it got stuck on a
recapture page. So, this is like a
headless agent. So, someone asked a
question about can I pass captures? What
now? You see that it's it got stuck
doing that. It looks like it's stuck in
a loop now. So, it sees the capture
again. So, I should skip the clip button
to skip the capture window. The capture
is still open. So, it it's probably
going to be stuck here unless I close
it. So, you can see there are
limitations. It's not going to pass
captures and whatnot. But that that was
a good query to show that it Oh, did it
fill it? It's still open. So, it's going
to be stuck here. So, I'm just going to
close it out. But you can see, you know,
it it can't pass everything. and can't
navigate through websites. So something
like that was will not work. So that was
a great test example to show.
If I use the the bakedin one, you know,
find that copy m under $50, it'll be
able to go through that and use headless
mode. But any questions on that? Seeing
how the MCP server is working. I didn't
have to write code. I just said do
something. It actually wrote the code to
to do it for me.
Question over here.
Yeah. Yeah. So, a question about if I
can actually go into the browser and do
it myself. Yeah. If I ran this locally
on my machine, it'll actually be able to
it'll open up the browser and I can
actually click the button and it'll
continue doing that. Right now, I'm
running it within the browser. So, I'm
de everything in headless mode. So, we
can't interact with that.
So, you can see it's able to find search
under $50. It can actually look at the
website. It's found search results on
Amazon.com. So yeah, so that for that
use case where we're not passing
captures is able to continue and find
the information there.
So a question about can I actually order
something? If I used my own browser
session and like logged in at to my
Amazon.com account and said yes, order
this for me, you know, click through,
it'll be able to understand that thing.
But I would have to put in I would have
to use my own browser sessions like I
wouldn't want to log in by myself. Yeah.
A question.
If you give Nova act the authentication
for Amazon for example like you give it
your login details then can it log in
and complete that action for you? Yeah,
if I if I like say this is my username,
this is my password, enter that into
that field and you'll be able to
understand, you know, this is a signin
button and I have this information. But
again, this is all Python code. So yeah,
you can encode it, you can make it an
environment variable so it won't read it
directly. So a lot of ways to do that.
Does it also like understand 2FA? Let's
say it asks you to go to your Gmail and
you will it then open the Gmail website,
check the email if you're logged in
again on your session and then input it
or is it and you can well if there's no
capture like we just thought of the
capture. Yeah. So there's no nothing
blocking. So but yeah again Nova Act is
free to use. So there's a lot of
creativity in this room. So I think we
should have like a Nova Act hackathon. I
think that would be you know do
something crazy with Nova Act.
All right. So, one more question. Yep.
One more. Can I book a flight when my
price alert is less than $100? It's like
a continuously check. You could probably
use something else for that. But yeah, I
mean, nobody can open up that website.
You can just have a query every day, you
know, open Google flights and look at
the quickest things and if something is
below this threshold, you know, send me
an email. So, again, this is all a
Python script. So, you can set up
something that triggers like once a day
like in a lambda function and so yes,
totally possible. So, Novax is very
flexible and because it can run in
headless mode, you don't need to have
that UI. So, that's really what makes it
helpful for interacting with websites
that don't have a native API.
Thanks. Yeah, this is pretty cool. I'm a
little bit confused. Like, we have the
Nova SDK SDK API key and we were also
doing some stuff in bedrock. Ah, yeah.
So how does this actually work? Yeah.
Yeah. So in the the Nova API key
separate but for this MCP client I did
it actually needs a large thing with
model to understand what's still
happening. So if I go to claude oops I
actually said I'm actually using claude
sonnet 3.5 for my MCP server. So that's
how because I just asked it you know
find that website for me. How how does
it know that without any of the code
doing that? So it's using a large
language model underneath the hood to
actually find that information. So
that's where we use bedrock for trying
to find it in the code but
sonnet. Yeah, I set the model ID. So
you're an AI system helping you have
tools you're using cloud 3.5 sonnet.
You're making an API call a bedrock
whenever something happens. So that's
where the the LLM we're using. But Nova
act is separate from that. So this MC
like if you're using you know claw
desktop it's running an LLM inside of
that to be able to understand that for
the MCP server
question here
question.
Uh the question is uh does it integrate
with browser plugins as well? Like could
it integrate with LastPass? If you have
the LastPass plugin, fill in the
credentials through LastPass and then
continue. I haven't tried that. But
again, it does you can set up to use
your own browser. So if you do that and
that's integrated, it might be able to
do that and click through that. But I
have not tested that, but something to
try out. Thank you.
And the biggest problem you would face
is two factor. Like even if you gave it
a password like if you're using
something like Google authenticator or
something that would be like the biggest
problem or capture but other than that
if you provide it environmental variable
or if you give it instructions on how to
access LastPass in the browser it should
be able to do it
right and uh oh one more question then
we'll go on to the last module.
So clearly there are a lot of different
uh agent architectures you could use. Um
and I can imagine using this as uh like
you have a coordinator agent set up
somewhere that's running in the overall
app and then when something pops up and
says hey you need to go and look this up
online go and check it. uh it should mod
so my question is how modular it I mean
it's just python so it should be pretty
modular right is that the way in which
you're imagining the architecture to be
is just if I was coding a coordinator
agent in lang chain or lang graph for
example it would then call your sub
agent and get and and run its stuff and
then get and then get a textbased output
that I throw into my message queue
that's how it all integrates together is
that right Yeah, that's one way you can
do it. So, Nova act again, right? It's
just Python. So, it could be a tool, it
could be an API call. And the next
module, we're actually going to show you
how to actually make an agent from that.
So, good good tea app right here. Uh, so
Dan talked about the strands uh at the
beginning. So, strands is a new agentic
framework launched by uh AWS. So, let me
open up the link. Uh, it's easy as a pip
install strands and the first agent is
like agent equals that. So it's very
it's a model first uh way of interacting
with agents. If you use a lot of agent
frameworks in the past, there's a lot of
bootstrapping and making sure everything
is correct and like but that was
necessary for kind of the older models
like if you think back to like like
Llama 2 for example, like how how far
models have evolved since then. So but
now we we can pass a lot of the you know
bootstrapping we did previously. The
agent can figure that out. So we don't
need all these very uh heavy weights and
like you know make sure everything's
typed and every so whatnot. So here's a
very simple example of how I actually
spun up uh and also it has MCP native
support. So in this example I actually
have two MCP servers. Uh I have the AWS
documentation and AWS diagrams MCP
server. So if you go to this like AWS
labs MCP, these are their official um
AWS MCP servers and there's a bunch of
different ones from like a cost
analysis, Nova Canvas, diagramming,
cloud form, uh lots of different ones
here. Uh so again, it's all on GitHub,
AWS Labs, MCP, but the example I do here
is I'm actually uh I made like a
solutions architect agent. Your role is
to help customers understand is building
on AWS. And I define these two MCP
servers here. I give it the prompt and I
say this agent has all the tools in the
MCP server. It has a bedrock model. I'm
using claude haiku here. And what's cool
about strand is it can also use like
light lm and o lama. So it has access to
launch of different things or you can
run it locally and of course it has
access to Amazon bedrock. So that's what
we're using here. So all those three
things makes the agent, the tools, the
model and the system prompt. And then I
can say uh get the documentation for AWS
Lambda and create a diagram of a website
that uses Lambda. So let me run this
code.
CD.
Okay. Okay, so it uses UV to install the
MCP server locally. A lot of people I
where does MCP run. This is running
locally, but there are other ways to run
it like in a lambda function and
whatnot. But for just testing it out, it
pulls down the the MCP server locally
and runs it. And you can see it's
already executing. So let's make this a
bit bigger. Uh
so it says, okay, I'm going to help you
with that. First, I'm going to search
the AWS Lambda documentation. uh read
the documentation, then I'll create a
diagram illustrating a static site. So
you can see it does a post request to do
the search. So the MCP server defines
where everything is. I don't have to
like feed it in the well architected
framework. The AWS documentation is
always updated. So it just knows called
the search function. It got the Lambda
welcome file. It it put that in. It's
able to generate the diagram. It it
generates the diagram. It tells us what
is going on, how the workflow looks
like. It tells me it saved the diagram
to this location. I can open it up.
Generated diagrams.
Oops.
And oh, it's very small. Let me see if I
can make this bigger.
There you go. So, it was able to
generate the diagram for me. So, all
through that about uh you know 40 lines
of code. I have two MCP servers. I have
my prompt and it's able to understand
that get that and just generate
something for me with that. Uh so that's
very easy to get started with strands of
building a agentic workflows. I know
agent means a lot of different things to
different people but you know you have
tools the model the system prompt do
some type of action and strands makes it
extremely easy to do that. If I use
other frameworks it could be a lot more
code to do something like that
especially integrating MCP natively like
that. I'm going to pause here for any
strands questions.
It's coming.
Um I know Bedrock already had it kind of
agents SDK. So is strands replacing that
or is this now the is this replacing
that or is it supposed to complement
that? Like is this the preferred way of
creating agents with models in bedrock?
Yeah. Well, when it comes to preferred
way, it always comes down to your use
case. So the bedrock agent has a lot
more I guess opinionated ways to do
things. It's you can do it through the
console. It has built-in support right
there in AWS. Well, strand is more as an
open source framework. So you can
download the code, you can use other
models through that like light lama. If
you use bedrock agent, you can't run
that offline. So there's different use
cases, different developer tooling. I
mean me as a software engineer, I like
you know code first doing things. So it
does depend on your use case, what
you're trying to do in your experience.
Can can you show the code real quick?
Yeah. Yeah, this is the code. Yeah, just
show the agent.
So, this is an open source framework. If
you go where it says agent, you and it
says model. Right now, we're using a
bedrock model, but you can use another
model with light LLM. Yep. So, you don't
need AWS at all in that instance.
Right.
Yeah.
So there's documentation anthropic
lightm uh lot of different model
providers lama open aai. So it's an open
source framework so you can use it
whatever you want. So but yeah that's
the idea with strand open source model
agent development kit.
One question suppose I want to build a
tax to SQL agent and I have um say 15
tools already built in that I want this
agent to be able to use. If I use this
framework, um, how can I make sure that
the agent know when to use the right
tool and the sequence? Yeah, great
question. Uh, so I didn't this example I
have a weather agent. So one thing you
said you already have tools. What I like
about strange a lot is I can write a
Python function I already have and let's
put this tool decorator and that's it.
You know, you don't have to put anything
else. it understands this is the uh what
you need to do and then when I'm going
to that agent I have this tools and it
has put in the the native tools we're
going to be using http request is a as a
standard tool in the strands framework
so in this example I'm like asking what
is the weather in Seattle and then also
how many words are in this response uh
this open API uh API weather.gov gov
where you don't need an API key and it
can find the information for you. So,
I'm gonna just update this San Francisco
and this
show wrong, but it's a figure it out.
Weather example, weather word count. And
I was very specific, you know, find the
weather first and then how many words
are in the response. So, it's able to
use that tool. It gets the forecast and
then it knows to use that word count
tool next. So, we're passing a lot of
the information to the model. The models
are very smart now. We don't have to say
do this, do this, do this. The let the
agent figure it out. That's kind of the
goal of the agent. You give it the
context and the tools necessary, it
figures out the best way to solve the
problem. But then wouldn't it be prone
to hallucination when you give it 20
tools and then because we've tried that
with AWS bar know the similar things
when you bind more I think more than 10
tools it's going to sure there's always
you know a balance but I again the
models are much better like try using
claw force on it. Is it hallucinating as
much? Like these newer models are much
better for understanding the concept and
understanding what tools when. The older
models sure they get confused. There's
so many things. But I'm very confident
on these newer models they can
understand your use case and what tools
available and figure out the best way to
solve the problem. So then with this
framework there wouldn't be a way for
you to orchestrate a customized flow but
more like you give the control to the
agent. You could if you want to have
like specific like do this specific way
uh there are different ways in strands
uh with something called workflow mode
where you actually say uh you know this
is the workflow I want to do research
results analyze things write a final
report if you have to do something very
sequential a strands has that I won't
have time to go through all the
different you know ways to do multi-
aent collaboration and whatnot but this
for that particular like I wanted to do
xyz first the workflow way can do that.
So yes, then is it possible say um I I
don't have a predefined workflow but I
know it needs to figure out the right
workflow then then that's what I just
did there. You know I just gave it a
sentence and figured it out. I see. I
see. Okay, perfect. Thank you
on it but um Cloud 4 has something
called interle thinking. I believe
that's what it's called where it can
handle multiple tools processing much
better than most models today. So if
you're passing in 20 tools, it's able to
work through the agentic loop to really
figure out which tool to run. And it's
also able to run parallel tool calls. So
rather than just say, okay, here's the
objective, let me run this tool. It can
say here's the objective, let me run
this tool, this tool, this tool, then
this tool, and then process the results
and determine what needs to happen next.
So I would try a cloud for which he like
Banjo mentioned.
Then last example really quick. Uh again
you know strands I made my Nova act MCP
server and it can actually run that you
know I define this is the MCP server use
the Nova MCP you know use the cloud. So
same type of thing I can have another
agent you know use uh nova act as well.
Uh so strands make it very easy to build
these agentic workflows. Uh so that's
really really enjoy the the developer
experience of using strands and you know
I already have the MCP server. We see
the same exact example before. So once
you have the MCP server, it's very easy
to plug in into different uh
architectures and strands makes it very
easy to to accept that.
Uh but yeah, those were the three
modules really about how to use strands.
Uh MCP then Amazon Nova ACT. Again, uh
Strand is open source. You can download
it pip install strands. Uh if you just
type strandagents.com, it'll take you to
the documentation.
again also Nova act nova amazon.com it's
free and log in
and then think that's all the time we
have but we do have a a survey uh and
you can get AWS credit code by filling
out this survey so I I have a question
about that workflow thing in uh strands
when you create these individual agents
can you define which tools are passed on
to each agents yeah yeah it's a great
question Dark about different agents
we're running out of time but I'll
quickly show uh I have a multi- aent
example I believe.
Oh I think you had it in the docs. Yeah.
Yeah, it's in the docs. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Each of these is a different
agent. So you know this is an agent. You
can have a different system prompt. You
can have different tools. So you're just
defining the agent and then yeah you can
have different tools, different whatever
there different models and then the
workflow would just call that. So yes,
completely customizable. So that's the
good thing about Strand. It's very easy
to customize and build scalable
solutions like that. Thank you. And then
again, uh here's the survey. You can get
AWS credits for filling out this thing.
Tell us how we did, what you liked, what
you want to learn more. And now go
build.
[Applause]
Yeah. Any other questions while we wait?
I think we have a minute.
Thanks for the presentation. Um so as
these systems develop I think that it's
reasonable to assume that um they would
emerge as an increasingly effective
vehicle for committing fraud online at
scale which would push businesses to
implement uh more things like capture
which kind of decreases the surface area
that tools like this would be
applicable. So what is the long-term
strategy for that? Well, you already saw
we failed to capture today. Like, you
know, we're not trying to b capture.
We're not trying to break things. You
know, a responsible AI is very important
to Amazon. So, no, we're not trying to
let this tool commit fraud. You know,
you have to have an API key, so it could
be monitored. So, use cases like that
will be shut down.
We
think we're done. Yeah. So, thank you
all.
I think it's finished.
Oh, we can keep going. We have more
time. Oh,
the clock the clock ran out. So, I
thought we were kicked out. All right.
Well, more questions then, I guess. I
thought Yeah, another question.
Um, so regarding Nova Act, let's say
that I have a headless browser in the
cloud. Is there a way to connect Nova
act to my custom browser instance in the
cloud? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You can there's
a way to like put your own browser
instance. So yeah, Nova supports that.
So possible. Yeah. Thanks.
Let me go to Novak GitHub page.
And just some examples there.
So yeah, there's a way to set up your
own user agent for Nova app. Definitely
possible.
Questions. Yeah.
Yeah. All right. Well, apparently I have
still more time. So, I don't know if
anyone actually got into the workshop.
So, we can still uh
build some stuff or I can try some other
examples.
Try to make Nova act.
I tried to make a stream app with Nova
Ax. So, we can try if that works.
Oops.
So, one example I tried, I tried to make
a Streamllet app that uh look for like
the top five uh PlayStation games on
game FAQs and then create an image like
a nice graph for me, but it it can fail.
So, uh I think that's one of the issues
there. I think it failed at one of the
steps there.
Uh
let's see. Oh, that Nova app got an
error. So,
it couldn't navigate game faqs.com. So,
it does it does fail at some of the
things. So, that's you know, again,
research preview. You have to be more
specific on how it goes through things.
Uh, but yeah, let me show you where the
the code is just so you can have an
example. Let me pull up the code.
Yeah, let me try let me set up my local
machine so we can see how it works.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Go for it. How much does Nova
act depend on like uh semantic HTML and
like good web design to actually work? I
mean it understands the actual page so
it can click through those things. But
if the if the page like doesn't have
like a search box or button and not be
able to navigate. So as long as the p it
can see the page, understand where to
click and then click those correct
buttons. So maybe a follow is there any
like efforts to do like experimental
like engagement on the page? So if it
comes on a page that it's not familiar
with, maybe it would try and act like a
human would to like click on things or
try things out depending what you you
put in that prompt because again you're
creating that workflow what it should
do. So if you say, you know, explore
this website and find things, it will
it'll try to click through that. But
again, it's up to kind of what that
initial prompt is that you have for it.
Yeah. When you're using overact, you're
kind of giving it step-by-step
instructions when you're using the SDK.
So that way, if you kind of know it's an
obscure website, you can give it those
instructions that it need to perform
rather than the MCP server um is using
natural language to infer what needs to
be done. So it's not specific
instructions
coming from you unless you provide it.
Yeah. So, I'm going to run it locally on
my machine just to show an example. Uh,
let's see.
Oh, let me hide my key for a second
because it's been recorded.
Python get coffee.
Thanks for coming.
All right. So, I'm just running it
locally on my machine. So, without
headless mode, so you can see it opens
up the browser.
It's able to type coffee maker.
So what we're looking at now is not in
headless mode. This is actually Nova act
actually performing the task in a
browser. So yeah
a lot of questions about how does it
work you know and we can try more
complicated examples. I just wanted to
show it could work on your machine
and you can see the log. You know, I'm
looking for and if I like change the
page while it's doing something, it's
going to like mess up. So, I'm going to
click the page and see what it does.
Like, so someone asked about click
things of that nature. What's it going
to do now?
So see it crashed now because I brought
I changed a different page didn't know
what to do. So example you can interact
with it when it's going through the
motion as well. And then I believe I
have an uh can the MCP server I set up a
cloud instance.
Oops.
And then I have a my Nova act MCP server
is there. So I'm able to actually you
know I click this you can see all the
tools it has available. So I can ask it
to like navigate a website. So uh
anyone have a complex example? You can
see the MCP server. So I know some
people have been asking some complex
examples. So get go ahead and give me
one
here. You got you got one.
You can try it. Do you have a specific
website that has like drag and drop?
Draw.io. Uh, let's go to draw.io. io and
make a cool diagram. Use Nova act.
Let's see what happens.
All right. So, let's go to draw IO. All
right. It opened the page.
Do I have to accept something? Nope.
It's going. Oops. All right. Open
dry.io. Let's see.
Make this smaller.
Wait for page to load. Look at my
initial setup for template selections.
All right, it's going. Uh.
Oh, it crashed.
What happened? Oh, do I have to allow
allow always?
Oh, it took a screenshot.
I need to continue the browser session
to see what's available. Let's look at
the screenshot. All right, it's opening
up again. Uh, it's going to draw.io.
Yeah, if I keep clicking away, it clicks
back to the di the browser session. So,
I need like two monitors.
See, is it going to figure out how to
use draw io?
Wait for pay. Take screenshot. Look for
template options. Come with blank pay.
All right. It's so it's kind of I didn't
give it any specific instructions. I
just said make something cool. So maybe
that's too hard to interpret for this
website. Maybe I have to say click this
click the square button and then drag
the square to the center or something. I
might have to been more explicit for
that.
It seems it seems to have frozen. All
right, it's clicking something. All
right, click new.
Oh, okay. Hey, it's doing stuff
again. It's not like super real time.
It's going. It's not like
instantaneously, but it it's it is
clicking through the buttons, clicking
through stuff.
All right.
Did it do anything? Oh, the CL. So, it
looks like it fa So, yeah, looks like
Claude failed that one. So, I won't
blame Nova for that. But that's the
that's the idea. So, thanks for trying
to do something hard.
All right, another question back there.
Oh, yeah. Can we can Can we try another
one? Yeah, let's try another one. Sure.
Can we do um you know on Google Maps,
find the top three rated coffee shops
with within a mile radius of this hotel.
Top three coffee shops
shops near the Marriott Marquees in San
Francisco.
You'll figure it out.
All right. Open Maps Google. Search Mary
Marque San Francisco. Wait for results
to load. So, it has a plan. It's going
to do something. So, let's see. It
opened Google Maps.
All right. Type MQ San Francisco. So,
it's able to type that.
Okay. It searched. It found the Marquee.
So, there's a copy button. Let's see if
it clicks that. I'm curious.
Looks like it's frozen.
Give it a couple more seconds.
What did it click?
It got this 15 minutes. I was trying to
type in that box. Okay.
All right. Just type in coffee shops.
All right. All right. It's going.
All right. So, all right. It'll open the
coffee shops and let's see if we can get
those top three. There's a 48 47 another
47. Let's see if it can get that.
Did it crash?
I think it did it, but I think I'm going
to blame Claude. Cloud desktop crashes.
might need a zip MCP client. Uh
yeah,
I think yeah, I think Claude Desktop
doesn't like doing that. But again,
because it's an MCP server, I can open
up a different MCP client. So I can open
like cursor, for example, and ask it
questions through that
cursor.
Let me close this.
And then
you see it has the MCP tools. Oops, it
has this up. Let me just open up a new
one. I can do the same thing and use
Nova act
and then it's calling the MCP tool
again. So that's the beauty of MCP. I
already have this server. I can just use
a different client. It can understand
all the information it needs to and do
the exact same command. So
it's going to do the same thing. cursor
might be smarter than cloud code.
But yeah, it's able to do the exact same
type of thing. So
a question over here. Yeah, I just got a
question.
Yeah.
Yes. So Novak question was where is
Novak running? And yes, it's running in
the cloud. So yeah, it's just you get
that API key and it's doing the call
behind the scenes in AWS cloud. Yeah. So
then what what does it upload to the
cloud? Well, it's asking the the
questions and like you know go to Google
Maps and then they say I understand that
and it's actually clicking those buttons
and doing the actions. So the the actual
uh intent of what you're trying to do in
the specific action
and if I was using it locally,
you couldn't use Nova act locally. It
has to be uh connected to the internet
to use it.
Okay.
But if I for example if I wanted to look
my
Yes.
Ah yeah I I see what you're saying.
Yeah. Yeah. If you I mean it is you know
it's a API endpoint. It's been passed to
AWS. So you know only pass information
that you feel like it's not going to be
we're not training the data or taking
any of that nature but it's going to the
AWS cloud and processing you know what
to click on this button locally on your
like browser.
So looks like it's not. Yeah. See, now
it's even certain the rating. It
actually knows which rating to press. So
So the Nova act is going to just give
the plan, right? Yeah. Yeah. Well, when
Nova act is is executing like in this
MCP server example, I say, you know,
find the top three copy stops in
Marriott near the Marriott marquee and
then I'm passing that information to the
the LLM to understand that plan and then
it uses Nova act to interact with the
browser because like cursor or cloud
code or Amazon Q, they can't interact
with the specific uh you know website by
itself. It uses it uses Nova act to do
that, right? But like given a question
though like how how does it come uh come
up with a plan? Oh the MCP server like
the the client so I picked the model in
the example we had the MCP client we had
this we showed the model I don't use
cloud 3.5 that's coming up with the plan
same thing here you know I asked you
know help me find the top three copies
of native Mario marquee this the model
that uh cursor is using is coming up
with that plan and then I'm using the
nova act mcp server to act on it.
Exactly. So this is the plan. Search for
Mary Marquee. Click the mirror marquee
you know search for the things and you
see all this information Nova act
returned and it actually it returned
this time. So I think the problem was
with claw desktop but it got the three
top three copy stops there. Right. What
are all the tools that uh Novaact can do
today. Uh so the MCP server is what I
wrote. So uh but the idea between Nova
act it can interface with the web
browser that that's the tool. The
browser is the tool and it can anything
that on the website can actually click
through, go through the example, etc. I
see.
You got the repo. Do you got an
architecture that shows the MCP just so
they can see it? Yeah. So, I mentioned
uh there's an official AWS MCP servers.
So, uh this AWS Labs MCP and a lot of
different um MCP servers here. For the
one, the Nova Act one, I created my own
one. uh go back to the nova act examples
or where do the ah here when I use
amazon to explain you know the am the
mcp server for like what what's going on
what tool was the browser session
performing an action on the browser so
this is a good uh thing to talk about so
can you dive deeper
on the browser action function and then
we can see because this is how it's
actually acting So, uh, Amazon Q browser
action is designed to perform actions.
It has this, uh, what's cool about it,
it just does, oops, let's go into the
code. It performs a single action in the
Nova act browser. So, it's executing
that action. It stores this act. act is
like what Nova says you know click the
search bar do this XY you know
why the MCP client understands how to
use this act that passes the correct
action so we saw the example here one of
the actions was like go to Google maps
or click this button or do that search
that's how it's able you know these
actions and then the nova act MCP server
is translating that to actually click
that button so the MCP server provides
all the interfaces it necessarily needs
So then these MCP clients can interact
and do actions and do things. Yeah. And
Nova act is just the model in the
background that's able to click those
buttons.
Extending this question, it so your MCP
server so claw uh or um cursor running
locally, right? It's calling your MCP
server that's also running locally. Is
your MCP and your MCP server is the one
that spun up the I guess the Chromium
instance, right? Is it is your MCP
server taking screenshots of what you
see in Chromium and shipping them to
Nova to Nova Act? The screenshots are
locally and then based on that like you
can see it's actually getting all the
information uh the final page
information. So it's not storing your
screenshot data and sending that
everything that it's running locally and
it's clicking those buttons based on
what's on the browser sensing. Got it.
But is is any of any of the information
in Chromium does that any of that need
to be sent into any form? Everything
running Yes. running locally. I have the
distinction. Okay, perfect. Thank you.
And let me open up the
Where's that looking?
So one of the things about making MCP
servers is you have to provide a lot of
context. So uh for no act like I say you
know when writing action for no action
be descriptive of what to do you know
click the hamburger menu icon go to
order history don't find my order. So
the more you know uh concise and
prescriptive what you want to do it's
better you know search for hotels in
Houston sort by average customer like so
the better specific it is uh that's how
the MCP uh client is able to make those
great requests and find the information
so type coffee maker search block enter
so so the more prescriptive you are of
nova act the better results you're going
to be and I encoded that all into this
uh MCP server so the clients can
leverage that
so I think that's Probably one of the
hardest things about making the MCP
servers that's making sure you provide a
next context of when to use the tool,
how to use the tool, the inputs and
outputs. But once you solve all that,
it's very easy to plug and play to
different MCP clients like we've done
here.
question. Yeah.
Right. So when Nova act is doing
something, it's passing back the log of
everything it's doing. So you know what
what steps it did. So the starting page,
the act the results, the action result
ID. So it's keeping a log of everything
it did. Uh power. So it's able to get
that JSON to understand what the ID what
the result is. So you can see what it's
doing so it can move on to the next
step.
Yep.
Make this bigger.
A question.
Sorry, a quick question. Yeah. Is this
able to do uh like uh automated UI
testing because of this?
Well, with Nova, you know, you can
define like what you want it to do. So,
you're going to have to define, you
know, go to this button, click this,
does this work? So, you can define that
workflow. So I mentioned before like
back in the day like if I'm writing
selenium code I have to go click this H1
tag do this like now you can just write
in natural language you know click this
button click that button so yes it can
handle that use case uh specifically of
like opening the browser checking these
things and but you have to like you know
this nova act search for coffee maker
you know you have you specifically have
to write what buttons to press.
Thank you.
See, guess if we have time, I can show
some multi- aent collaboration with
strands. That could be something cool.
Uh, I think I have a repo for that. So,
should be
uh go to the AWS labs page. Where's that
work?
and then claude.
Cool.
Okay,
I'm just going to copy this code and put
it into our environment.
So in this example, I'm actually going
to show how strand says multi- aent
collaboration. So one uh way I'm
actually going to create a PowerPoint
presentation based on uh you know a
cloud migration request. I want to like
move my u infrastructure on premise to
the cloud. give me a presentation of how
I would do that. And so for this, I
created three different agents. I
created a cost analysis agent. So I have
a system prompt there, a solutions
architect agent to map out what you're
going to be doing. And then each of
these uh tools is an actual agent. So
this uh costbus has the docs MCP server,
the cost analysis MCP server. It has its
own prompt. The presentation agent has
its own system prompt. It has a tool
from there's a a PowerPoint MCP server
that I'm using and then there's an
architecture agent that also has you
know its own specific tools system
prompt etc. So uh different agents for
different uh things in the workflow and
then I have this orchestrator agent what
I've called the migration orchestration
agent. It has a prompt. I tell it what
tools it has access to. And then the
cool thing with strands is I make this
orchestrator agent and then the tools or
this other agents in that. So it knows
when to call this agent for this
particular tool when to do that and I
say you know I want to migrate my work
my uh workload. So write the right tools
to find that. So I made a fictional
company called shop easy e-commerce.
They have onremise Java MySQL database.
I want to zero down from migration like
all this all these little constraints in
there and I wanted to make a migration
plan and a PowerPoint presentation that
I can present to my executives of how
this would work and I just assigned and
I'm the orchestrator agent will find out
what to do. I don't specifically say do
this one first, do that first. We'll let
the the agent figure that out. So let me
run that strands
and it should be multi- aent
right so cloud partition agent as tools
all right again so all the MCP server is
running locally it downloads it's using
the UX it start with the architecture
design first generates a diagram
going to use W. So take some time. It
might fail but it would just update
update itself.
Making another judgment.
All right. Think it couldn't generate
the diagram there, but it's saying all
right. That's going to this is what the
diagram should have. This is what we're
going to doing.
Now it's going to do a cost analysis
cost analysis on based of the things we
did there. So it's it's a this workflow
takes maybe a couple minutes to run. But
you can see it's calling all these
agents uh different things. It's
understanding what to do, what actions
to take first. It's finding pricing for
EKS because it has the uh cost analysis
tool and knows where to find that
information. So it has the up-to-date
pricing all the time finding for Aurora
for its database. So it's able to
understand all that information and get
real time up-to-date information just
because we have that uh pricing MCP
server from the AWS labs example
pricing
is it oh cost analysis.
Yeah, cost analysis, MCP server
documentation, all the stuff you need
for finding the right price on AWS. It
has all that information and the agent
was able to just use that once it's
going to generate a report.
So, it's still running. Again, this does
take a while because I'm asked a very
complex question, a lot of things going.
Uh, so it does take a couple minutes to
run through all that. It gets it monthly
spend predictions, monthly savings, etc.
So, it's able to understand all the
information and get all up-to-date
information based on the plan we've
provided.
And the last thing now wants to create
an executive presentation. So, download
the PowerPoint MCP server and now it's
going to make a PowerPoint presentation
based on that.
So, adding the title slide. So, you
know, add a placeholder. So generating
powerpoints is a very popular use case
and there's an MCP server that can go
ahead and just do that add bullet points
etc.
So give it a couple another minute or